- I believe that the Yale
School of Public Health
has the chance to define public health,
scholarship, education, and practice
for the next century,
to define who's part of public health,
how we do it, how we identify
and address health problems
in an inclusive, equitable,
and impactful way.
The ultimate objective
for the Yale School of Public Health
is for us to be recognized
globally as the school
that is transforming the
future of human health.
(gentle symphonic music)
I see there being four pillars
of a school of public health
that defines the future of our field.
Those are inclusivity.
It is, of course, core to
the field of public health,
but it's also how we are going to succeed
as we move forward.
Inclusivity is about having a
diverse, equitable, inclusive,
and belonging-focused
environment within our school
for faculty, staff, and students.
But it's also about being inclusive
of community voices, of lived experience,
of folks who we may not
traditionally think of
as being part of public health at all.
Innovation and entrepreneurship,
making sure that we're set up to make sure
that public health innovations
can thrive in either for-profit
or not-for-profit environments.
The third pillar is around communication.
As we learned all too well during COVID,
it's essential for all
of us, students, faculty,
and the world at large
to know how to communicate
about public health
and scientific knowledge.
The last pillar that is essential for us
as we move forward
into the public health
school of the future
is around data-driven leadership.
That's the ability for us to
use our disciplinary skills
to identify problems, gather data sets,
to look at the details,
and then figure out what to do next.
Public health is only as good
as the action that we
take at the other side,
the impact that we have
on the health of our local community,
as well as the nation and the globe,
those are the skills that we
have to impart in our students,
but also that we as faculty
and staff and alumni,
need to be dedicated to.
(gentle symphonic music)
C.E.A Winslow founded our
School of Public Health
108 years ago,
based on the idea that
core to public health
is the community,
and also core to public health
is empowering the community for change.
That's one of the philosophies
that informs my leadership
style in general,
informs my decision to assume the deanship
here at the Yale School of Public Health,
and that is core to our function
as a school of public health,
but going forwards, it is
incumbent on us to do more.
Public health only succeeds
when we have the public at its core,
when we listen to, partner with,
and sometimes are led by
the needs of the communities
in which we work.
(gentle symphonic music)
As an emergency physician,
I know that I'm only as good
as the team that I work with,
and so my commitment as a leader
is to making sure that everyone on my team
is set up for success,
knows what their role is,
and is empowered to do
everything that they can
for the greater good.
(gentle symphonic music)
Oh, here at Yale, we
have tremendous potential
to influence and make progress
on firearm injury prevention,
both within the School of Public Health,
but also in partnership with
other schools across Yale.
We have a number of brilliant researchers
at the Yale School of Public Health
who are already thinking about
many of those baseline risk factors
for firearm injury and how to modify them.
We have a tremendous
opportunity to set the standard,
not just as an academic community,
but as a city, and as a state,
that can help lead the rest of the nation.
Thank you, from the bottom of my heart
for your commitment to the
Yale School of Public Health.